>>> OUR HEALTH LEAD NOW, THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES CREATED
BY THE SUPREME COURT'S
OVERTURNING OF ROE V. WADE AND
THE MOVE BY POLITICALLY
CONSERVATIVE STATES TO ENACT
ABORTION BANS AND OTHER SEVERE
RESTRICTIONS.
CNN'S ELIZABETH COHEN INTRODUCES
US TO A COUPLE THAT WAS FORCED
TO MAKE SOME WRENCHING CHOICES
AND HAVE BECOME VOCAL SUPPORTERS
OF ABORTION RIGHTS.
>> Reporter: LAST SPRING JILL
HARDLE TOOK A PREGNANCY TEST AND
WAS THRILLED TO FIND OUT SHE WAS
EXPECTING.
WITH A LITTLE GIRL, SHE AND HER
HUSBAND MATT NAMED HER IVY
GRACE.
THEIR MAMA AND PAPA BEAR
INSTINCTS KICKING IN RIGHT AWAY.
>> I IMMEDIATELY FELT LIKE A DAD
AND FATHER.
MY WHOLE GOAL IS TO PROTECT MY
FAMILY.
>> Reporter: AND MATT WOULD NEED
TO PROTECT THEM AT AN ULTRASOUND
WHEN JILL WAS FOUR MONTHS
PREGNANT.
>> OUR DOCTOR CAME IN THE ROOM
AND IMMEDIATELY YOU KNEW THAT
SOMETHING WAS WRONG, AND SHE
SAID HER HEART ISN'T WHAT WE
WANT IT TO LOOK LIKE.
>> Reporter: THAT ULTRASOUND AND
ANOTHER A MONTH LATER FOUND IVY
GRACE HAD A SEVERE AND
DEVASTATING HEART DETECT.
SOUTH CAROLINA LAW GAVE THEM TWO
CHOICES, CARRY IVY GRACE TO TERM
AND SHE WOULD DIE SHORTLY AFTER
BIRTH, OR SUBJECT HER TO
MULTIPLE EXTENSIVE OPEN HEART
SURGERIES, WHICH SHE MIGHT NOT
SURVIVE.
JILL IS A HAIRDRESSER AND FORMER
MS. SOUTH CAROLINA, MATT A
BREWER.
THEY WERE RELIGIOUS REPUBLICANS
IN A RED STATE.
>> I GREW UP IN A CHRISTIAN
CONSERVATIVE HOUSEHOLD.
I'M A VERY FAITHFUL WOMAN.
>> Reporter: LIKE MANY PARENTS,
WITH A SEVERE AND DEVASTATING
DIAGNOSIS, THEY OPTED TO
TERMINATE THE PREGNANCY.
>> THE BEST OPTION WAS TO
PROTECT OUR DAUGHTER FROM PAIN
AND SUFFERING WAS TO SEND HER TO
HEAVEN.
>> Reporter: BUT ABORTION WAS
NOT AN OPTION IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
THEY FOUND A CLINIC OUT OF STATE
BUT IT HAD A TWO-WEEK WAIT.
>> THOSE TWO WEEKS WERE PROBABLY
THE MOST TORTUOUS TWO WEEKS OF
MY ENTIRE LIFE.
>> IT WAS A LOGISTIC NIGHTMARE.
>> ALL WHILE YOU'RE GRIEVING THE
LOSS OF YOUR CHILD.
>> NOW THEY'VE START TODAY IVY
GRACE PROJECT TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC.
FETAL ANOMALIES CAN'T BE
DETECTED UNTIL FIVE MONTHS INTO
A PREGNANCY WHEN IT'S TOO LATE
IN STATES LIKE SOUTH CAROLINA TO
HAVE AN ABORTION.
>> IT'S NOT FAIR FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO TELL YOU WHAT YOU
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT DO.
>> Reporter: CNN REACHED OUT TO
THE PRIMARY SPONSOR OF THE MOST
RECENT LAW.
STATE SENATOR LARRY GROOM SAID I
REGRET TO HEARD ABOUT THE FAMILY
AND THEIR BABY WITH A HEART
DEFECT.
HOWEVER, I REMAIN COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING THE LIVES OF CHILDREN
FROM THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO END
THEIR LIVES.
AS THE HOLIDAYS APPROACH, SO
DOES THE DAY THEIR DAUGHTER
WOULD HAVE BEEN BORN.
>> THE 25th IS CHRISTMAS, JILL'S
BIRTHDAY IS THE 26th AND THE DUE
DATE WAS THE 27th.
>> WE JUST DON'T WANT ANOTHER
FAMILY TO HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THE
PAIN WE'VE HAD TO EXPERIENCE.
>> Reporter: HOW, THEY SAY THEY
DON'T BLAME THEIR DOCTORS IN
SOUTH CAROLINA FOR NOT
PERFORMING THE TERMINATION.
THEY SAY THEY KNOW THAT THE LAWS
WERE CHANGING QUICKLY LAST
SUMMER AND THEIR DOCTORS COULD
CONCEIVABLY HAVE FACED HEAVY
FINES, THEY COULD HAVE FACED
PRISON TIME, SO THEY DON'T BLAME
THEM.
THE COUPLE SAYS SHE JUST WANT
SOUTH CAROLINA LEGISLATORS TO
KNOW THAT MANY CONSERVATIVE
CHRISTIANS LIKE THEMSELVES DO
NOT SUPP